ん
の
こんにちははじめ鉄王ですはいというわけで最後に出すとのいつだっけなもう結構前な
んですけどもみなさまお待たせいたしました
質問コーナーの募集動画0
pa
[音楽]
はいというわけであのなんやかんやんいつも皆さん質問コーナーの質問あれあみなさん
いつも質問コーナーのボス動画にあのボスですあの皆さんいつも質問コーナーの質問
募集動画にコメントしてくださって本当にありがとうございますい全部本当にすげー
たくさんコメントくるんで全部見るのがすごく大変なんですけどサ
の穂がやっぱり正しいちゃったあの本当にコメントたくさん見るの巣が大変なんです
けどもそれの僕はのその中で御国を背負い込むと見つけどんどんが大変なことなんです
よね動画のコメント欄をいつも見てその面白いコメントを見つめる
違ったあっ最も乾麺とランドあのコメントを見て面白いコメントを見つけるのがすごい
大変なんですけれども皆さんの面白いコメント
止めなんて3
者さんのコメントのコメントラーの
あの皆さんのコメント欄に書いておけるいつもコメントを見てあの
ほ面談のコメントを見てあの面白いコメントを見つけるのですが大変なんですけども
あのいつもお揃いコメントありがとうございますコメントが母数期間なんですけども
へと強化5月の5日ということで5月の中旬だった5月の15日半ばまで
コメントのあのコメントの募集をしようと思います
あのコメント欄に書くことは本当に何でもいいですあの中には
ん
いつもコーナーといつもあの室もうこんなじゃないみたいなとこあるのでもと質問でも
いいですし
リクエストでもいいし僕に言いたいポットでもいいし
文句でもいいです文句でもいいし暴言をちょっと控えめでお願いしますもうなんでも
いいのでえっと5月の15日の24時まで
皆さん好きなことをこの動画のコメントに書いていただけれ道具
あのバカとねありがたいと思っておりますコメントタイムですの縛る早口言葉でも言っ
てみようかなと思ってるんでその間に皆さん是非コメントの方にコメント
よろしくお願い致します東京突極結核東京特許許可局
あっ見えました海辺ぴょこぴょこピークああ立ててビッグ見込み浮かぶコポピっこれっ
かえぴょんこぴょんこあーてピョコピョコピュア
[音楽]
隣の客はよく柿急遽経過や屏風が間違えた
これ坊主が屏風に上手に坊主の焼かれたん
かえるぴょこぴょこ急行パースでぴょんぴょんぴょんぴょ校
はいみなさん動画のコメントに質問リクエストなんか色々かけることできました
でしょうか
えっと5月の15日で締め切ってだいたい多分出すのがえっと5月数中に出せればいい
なと思っております
うそーと5月の2今日まで皆さんがをボス
雨繋がコメントお待ちしておりますバイバイ
ランランそれよ
[音楽]
me
car
あっはぁ
あー巻がにあ倶楽部がおまっ
青は機が約が磨き頑張りますんはぁっ